[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL GRIFFIN: Thanks
so much, guys.
So I'll try and talk
for about half an hour
or 40 minutes or something
about the origin of the project,
or give it a little bit
of context and explain.
The first thing I suppose
I need to kind of demystify
is that very frequently
people assume
that it's some kind
of wish-granting app
where like miraculously
you're gonna
kind of make stuff happen.
The app doesn't do that.
It takes one positive
action every day
in the direction of travel
in terms of what it is
that people have articulated.
But I'll specify that
a little bit more.
And then, as I say, talk about
the history of the project,
where it came from,
exemplify some of the actions
that the app takes,
and then talk
a little bit about what the
conceivable future of it
might look like.
And then, as I say,
I hope at the end
we'll have time for questions.
I've always got to
caveat this talk
by saying that we've had a
couple of technical issues
with regards to
setting up the slides.
So if at some point
the screen goes dark,
then you'll have to
forgive me while I try
to remember how to reboot it.
So just a tiny bit
about my background.
I've always worked in the
kind of media sectors.
So mainly in television,
and for a brief spell
for a couple of years at
the radio station KISS FM.
I've worked for a bunch
of advertising agencies
for Channel 4, and
also Comedy Central,
the Viacom-owned brand.
And I about probably
four years ago I just
turned 40, a classic midlife
crisis style of thing.
And I've had this idea.
And I thought if I
don't now do something
about putting it into the
world and making it happen,
maybe it will never
kind of manifest.
And there were three principle
kind of creative influences
that I had.
Not necessarily things that
I was utterly obsessed with,
but they're just things that
caught my attention, that I'd
maybe bought a book or looked
into them a little bit further.
The first of these was a
project called Post Secret.
I don't know whether
anyone's heard of this.
But a guy in the States
called Frank Warren,
not to be confused with the
English boxing promoter,
asked people to hand make
a postcard on which they
articulated something that they
had never told another living
soul, and to anonymously
send it to him.
And he received literally
hundreds of thousands
of postcards, this guy.
He's done six books now.
He does exhibitions,
speaking tours.
What started as a
kind of reasonably
understated and scruffy Tumblr
blog became this phenomenon.
And I was interested, I
suppose, at the little snapshots
that this gave into
people's lives.
There was no back story.
Although often it's possible
to kind of imagine what
it might have been.
And you didn't really
know what happened next.
But just this idea of a brief
glimpse into someone's kind
of soul was something
that I found really
kind of engaging in terms of the
authenticity of it, I suppose.
Super unpolished, very
authentic, as I say,
and something which
kind of resonated.
Very frequently kind of
melancholic, as well.
I smile all the time so that
no one knows how sad and lonely
I really am.
The type of stuff that in this
increasingly kind of polished
world of social
media we would be
unlikely to post, say,
on Instagram or something
like that.
Something that felt like
because of the anonymity,
people's identities
weren't associated with it,
felt like it was coming from
a kind of truer place to me.
There was another thing that
I really, really did like--
and this I did buy
all the books--
are called "Found Magazine."
And this, again, was a kind
of pretty understated project
started by a guy
called Dave Rothbart.
And he just produced
a compendium of notes
that either people sent
him or that he found.
And that was it.
And again, it provides a
similar kind of little snapshot
into people's lives.
And there was something
super fascinating about it.
And they were
simultaneously disposable.
Literally, they were trash
that he found in the street,
but also I thought kind of
potent and really interesting.
Call me.
Dad died.
I wonder what's kind
of going on there.
What's the nature of
that relationship.
This one here I really like.
Mario, I fucking hate you.
You said to me
that you had work.
Then why is your car
here at her place?
You're a fucking liar.
I hate you.
I fucking hate you.
Amber.
PS.
Page me later.
So those kind of
things were, as I say,
it told you everything
about someone and nothing
about someone simultaneously.
And I was really into that.
Also, and this has
become a tiny bit
of a kind of millennial
cliche, you could argue.
It has maybe 15 million
followers on Facebook now.
This Humans of New York project
that you'll be familiar with.
Photographer called
Brandon Stanton
just meeting people in New
York and taking photos of them
and hearing what it is that they
have to say about their lives
in a paragraph or two.
And there's some
extraordinary kind
of wisdom contained therein.
There's some amazing
pathos contained therein.
There's some super-inspiring
stuff as well.
But again, I guess
what links these three
projects that as I say, I
was kind of preoccupied with,
was they just provided this
limited little snapshot, almost
like a Polaroid, as I
say, of someone's soul.
So I was thinking about this
kind of concept for a while.
And I was also
looking, I suppose,
without doing some
wholesale like, you know,
competitive analysis of what
the marketplace looked like.
I was seeing the kind of
apps that were out there.
At the time there were
a few anonymous ones--
Whisper, which is
still quite a big deal.
One called Secret,
which has kind of segued
into being something
else, and another app,
which was super popular for
a while on college campuses
in the States called
Yik Yak, all of which
were anonymous apps
which again, allow
people within your network
to say something which they
probably wouldn't say
were they in a position
to have to associate their
own identity with it.
So I thought, you know, let's
create an anonymous place where
people can post the things
they most want in the world,
whatever those things may be.
And that was my initial
iteration of the idea.
So I'm a reasonable devotee of
the lean startup methodology,
and a lot of the
Paul Graham essays--
you know, the Y
Combinator founder.
And what I didn't do was
to go out and try and raise
VC capital or
anything like that.
I did a super scruffy, low-cost
iteration of this primary idea.
And its sole function
was just for people
to articulate in 100 characters
or less, as I say, the things
that they most wanted,
whatever those things may be.
And I kind of thought when
I was like building it
with a developer
guy, well, maybe that
will just be like what it is.
But when I looked
at it, and we tried
a little bit of a beta test,
and I got some user feedback,
paradoxically, something
which was designed
to be a little
inspiring ended up
feeling slightly kind
of flat and listless.
Because what was happening was
there were people, as I say,
were articulating their hopes,
dreams, desires, aspirations.
But if nothing was
happening as a consequence,
it ended up feeling like
a slightly deserted kind
of Pinterest board where
people had like put this stuff.
But it just was a repository for
half kind of forgotten dreams
and thwarted ambition.
So it ended up, as I
say, feeling a little bit
kind of tired and strangely,
a slightly depressing place
to hang out.
So the thing that
I suppose catalyzed
it-- and I wouldn't want to
over-exaggerate the extent
of the success of the project.
It's not like it's some
Snapchat style phenomena.
But the thing that people seem
to kind of gravitate towards,
or that galvanized
it, was this idea
of taking meaningful,
real world action.
So I'm really very
interested in technology,
but equivalently interested--
as we all are, I'm sure--
about the kind of things that
happen away from keyboard.
So I thought, could you
do an interesting thing?
And I was quite into these
projects where the app
itself was like a
nicely designed thing.
Take Airbnb, for example.
That's a cool app.
You could design it in
loads of different ways.
Website looks nice.
Endlessly kind of changed and
iterated to try and perfect it.
But the amazing thing
about being Airbnb
was the fact that
millions of people
were having these
extraordinary weekends
where they met
someone who became
a friend in a foreign city.
That was really what
the user experience was.
That was the real kind
of UI right there.
So I thought, is
there something cool
that you could do to bring
these aspirations a little bit
closer?
Not to miraculously,
like I said at the start
of the presentation,
and as it says up here,
not granting wishes
in the way that you
might see in a kind of
children's fairy story
or schmaltzy Disney thing.
But just, I suppose,
adhering to the credo
that any action is
better than none.
Is there something
that we can do
about each of these
wishes that makes them
a three-dimensional real
thing, a couple of steps
closer to that
professed aspiration,
rather than it just hanging
around on the internet being
like another tweet or something.
And that was all the
kind of thinking was.
So the site's actions are unique
and freshly created every day.
And they can be
anything, depending
on the nature of the wish.
And you see, like
those three projects
I was talking
about at the start,
you see things which are
happy or sad or melancholic or
uplifting.
The interesting thing about
it-- or one of the interesting
things that I've
found about it--
is that no two wishes
are kind of alike.
And a wish which is super
kind of sad and heartbreaking
seems to sit quite happily
alongside another wish which
might be, as I say, uplifting
or euphoric in some way.
So there were only
a few guidelines,
which people have been
pretty good at adhering to.
Of the many thousands of
wishes there are on the site,
I've probably had
to delete like six.
I think most of them are
from the same person.
And as it says here, basically--
I don't know how well
you can read that.
Don't be lame.
You know, it's not that
funny to kind of write oh, I
wish I could fly or whatever.
Don't be greedy.
So say, I wish I had a
free Rolex or whatever.
That's not going to
get any traction.
And the way in which the site
was working in terms of its UI
is that the wish that was
most up-voted each day,
the wish that came to the
top of the list, the top
of the charts, as
it were, that was
the one that was going to have
some action taken against it.
Don't be a dick.
So any form of
behavior that advocates
kind of breaking the law or
some kind of racial hatred
or something like that.
That was just going
to get taken down.
Don't be gross.
Don't be too selfish.
Et cetera.
PS, we've heard the thing
about unlimited wishes loads.
It's hilarious.
So people seem to
kind of understand.
It self-governed
pretty well, the site.
And if occasionally there
is something weird on there,
someone will typically
email me and say, you know,
you should check out this wish.
It looks a bit odd.
But as I said, they were
all completely anonymous.
100 characters or less.
And the wish that got
to the top every day
at 6:00, that was the one that
had action taken against it.
So let me give you some
examples of the actions
that the app takes.
So quite a lot of Trump
stuff at the moment,
for obvious reasons.
So this is-- I
think the wish was
I wish that Donald Trump
wasn't such a dick.
But I've had variance
of that loads of times.
So that's a thought that
probably everyone has had.
What you get from
this project is
that I actually wrote a letter
to him at the Trump Foundation.
Weird that he never
wrote back to me.
I don't know.
He must be busy.
But it's just a kind
of slightly snarky,
why did you once tweet "tiny
children are not horses"?
Everyone knows that already.
What were you thinking
when you said,
"If Ivanka weren't my daughter,
perhaps I'd be dating her."
Can you not see
that's kind of gross?
Et cetera, et cetera.
And that stuff, in terms
of growing the site,
goes over pretty
well on Twitter back
when Twitter was
still like a thing.
That's a dig at your
competitor there.
And so sometimes I'll do
something in the spirit
of the wish itself.
So that's clearly a
tongue-in-cheek, slightly
ironic wish.
And so the response
is equivalent.
When people wished--
there's quite a lot of stuff
about the elderly, you know.
There's a phenomenon
in this country--
and to a certain
extent in the States--
where there's an
epidemic of loneliness
amongst old people
in this country.
And very frequently, I
forget what the statistic is,
but it's a high percentage of
people, or a surprisingly high
percentage of people,
will go like two weeks
without having any form
of human interaction
beyond the most prosaic one
with a shopkeeper or a postman
or something.
So when people wish for a
treat for the elderly, myself,
or my girlfriend-- thank you
very much for helping me with
that--
visited an old people's
home over the Easter weekend
and festooned it with hundreds
of daffodils and chocolate
eggs.
When people wished that their
commute wasn't so boring,
I changed the
signage on the Tube.
So it's very easy to download--
as I discovered-- the London
Underground typeface.
And I just adjusted the
signs to give people
a bit of a smile on
their way to work.
So as I say, it's
one thing every day.
And I don't, like,
go into a thing
where I say, I'm going to do
every tube train or whatever.
It's what you're buying
in inverted commas,
although it's free,
what you're buying into
is 24 hours worth
of resourceful,
industrious, hopefully
creative kind of action.
But everything starts and ends
within that 24-hour period.
I never say, I'll get
back to you in three weeks
once I've got 1,000
signatures or something.
This was a wish from
a woman in Scotland
whose daughter had been badly
bullied in secondary school.
So she came down to London.
And we arranged a really
nice day out for her.
I use "we" in the royal sense.
I mean I arranged a
nice day out for her.
And she went-- what did she do?
We met for breakfast.
And then she went
to the Royal Ballet
and had a kind of
backstage tour there.
She was really interested,
like a lot of teenagers
are, in a potential career
in the performing arts.
So she met a ballet dancer and
had a kind of backstage tour
there.
And then the ballet dancer
gave her ballet shoes,
which was really sweet.
Then she went to
Pineapple Dance Studios
and met with someone who'd
been a backing dancer for One
Direction and lots of
people, and gave her
a kind of dance class.
Then she went to meet a friend
of mine who I knew from my time
at KISS FM who's a super
nice, very, very sweet,
charismatic woman who
is one of the DJ's.
She does the afternoon
drive-time show.
And so she had a cup
of coffee with her
and talked to her
about this experience
that she was having in school.
And then in the evening
she went to a performance
of "Mamma Mia."
And she wore all
black and was sitting
at the side of the stage
with the stage manager,
and saw how that kind of
whole show was put together.
And a couple of those
things were people
that I knew already.
But a couple of those
things were people--
and this happens quite a lot--
who were already on the site.
All four of those people
had been bullied themselves
when they were little.
And they said, oh, I see
you've got this wish coming up
about bullying.
Well, I would be really happy.
I'm an actress now.
She should come
down to "Mamma Mia."
Or this person at
the Royal Opera House
can help in this particular
way with the ballet, et cetera,
et cetera.
So very frequently I'll
be coordinating something
which the community
itself is volunteering
in terms of what it is that
they might like to do to help,
which is kind of nice.
You remember a while
back where Boko Haram,
the Islamic fundamentalist
group in northern Nigeria,
kidnapped those
schoolgirls, some of whom
have now been released.
And so I went to the
Nigerian Embassy first thing
in the morning before it opened
and had written the night
before the name of
each of the missing
girls on a Post-it
note, and then
covered their doors with
that as a kind of gesture.
And very frequently, as
I said, it is a gesture.
So I'm not claiming
that as a consequence
of me doing that, the girls
were miraculously recovered.
It's just an articulation,
a visualization,
a 3D iteration of that
which would otherwise just
be a bit of social media
kind of ephemera, I suppose.
You know who I mean
by Katie Hopkins?
It's like a female Piers Morgan.
Someone wished that she
would sign a gagging order.
And by a very
strange coincidence,
I was reading a
magazine in the week
before this wish
came to the top.
And I saw that she was due
to do a speaking event where
she was going to be in
some debate about Brexit
or something.
And so I went along
to that debate.
And I folded over
a piece of paper,
got her to sign the bottom
here with her lame signature,
which has a pathetic
little heart.
And little did she
know that clearly it
wasn't legally binding.
It was just like a joke.
But she said, in fact, I'm
so embarrassed with pretty
much everything I've ever done.
OK.
Now that joke only works
if you know who she is.
But she's a fairly
reprehensible human being.
Very frequently they
are about things,
social ills that we can
see around us-- the wishes.
So if people wish for
help for the homeless,
I'll just go out,
again, not miraculously
claiming to rid the
world of the problem
that it has with
homelessness, but just
visit half a dozen people,
take them some sleeping bags,
a cup of coffee, sandwiches at
lunchtime, whatever it may be.
When people wish for
more love in the world,
but quite often they're
quite abstract things
like that, which as an
expression of something
or a nice sentiment, but
they're kind of woolly.
So I'll try and do something
kind of crisp and specific
with regards it.
So on this occasion,
people wished
for more love in the world,
and then distributed flowers
all over London.
And so people can
take them back,
give them to their
boyfriend, girlfriend,
partner, whatever, tell them
how much they love them.
That was pretty popular.
There was this thing I wasn't
aware of, this phenomenon.
But there's a very popular wish
where people felt that when
they went to an up-market
department store--
Harrod's or Selfridges
or whatever--
they were frequently
condescended to
by people who worked
on makeup counters.
I didn't know that
that was a thing.
But apparently it was.
Lots of people said, oh, yeah.
That happens to
me the whole time.
So I put this sign in Harrod's.
"Customers should
be advised that they
may be subject to
withering looks
and occasional
condescending comments.
We trust this will not detract
from your shopping experience."
This again was the
community helping.
So this was a really
sick boy in Florida
who just wanted to get
a lot of birthday cards.
And so Crowdwish members
sent them to him.
This was the thing--
remember, this
was another arcane
bit of tax law.
I actually think it was with
EU legislation, rather than
something that was maybe under
our kind of aegis in the UK.
But feminine hygiene
products were
taxed as a luxury item,
which was obviously insane.
And there was quite lot of
stuff online about that.
So I sent this tampon
in this luxury packaging
to the Chancellor
of the Exchequer
with a sarcastic note.
This was people wishing there
was less bigotry in the world.
So I sent-- have you ever seen
that website, Ship Your Enemies
Glitter?
It was like a big deal
a couple of years ago.
You know, because glitter is
a fucking nightmare, isn't it?
It you open an envelope.
And so I sent this--
EDL or something it was
called, like a horrible kind
of far right extremist group.
So I sent the
leader of that one.
To think of the kind of
campus thing I could do.
So I had a vision whether
or not this manifested.
I don't know.
Sometimes it would be
nice to see, to be there
when this stuff happens.
But I had a vision of this
guy getting covered in glitter
and reading this.
Sorry, not sorry.
When someone wished for
a half-decent boyfriend,
I put up a kind of missing
sign, presumed non-existent,
just not a dick, basically.
And again, what happens with
these things is you only
need to put out one sign.
I had actually put
up more than that.
But I think I put up less
than half a dozen signs.
And then someone sees
it, takes a photo of it.
And by the end of the day, I
had a load of people getting
in touch saying, either
I am that boyfriend,
so if you find
someone, then I am
the candidate who ticks
all this kind of criteria.
I have my own teeth,
positive bank balance,
et cetera, et cetera.
Or a lot of people
saying look, if you
do find this
mythological man, who
I'm convinced doesn't
actually exist,
then let me know, because I'd
love to have to have a date.
So I probably put together
seven or eight couples.
And again, I don't
follow that narrative.
I just say, look, I'll
introduce you guys.
I hope you have a
good time, basically.
When people wish that--
this is like a political
thing by the way.
But you know, Jeremy Corbyn
was getting quite a lot of shit
for looking scruffy.
And he did look
pretty bad, I thought.
He did look kind of scruffy.
And David Cameron--
didn't he say
something to him at the
PMQs about my mother
would be ashamed of
you, or something.
I can't remember what it was.
But anyway.
A friend of mine runs
this shirt company
called Charles Tyrwhitt.
So I called him--
Nick Wheeler he's called--
and said, can you send
me some smarter clothes?
And I swear that I have seen
Jeremy Corbyn wear this.
I swear I have.
I noticed that he
didn't declare it.
Because I thought, how
am I going to find out?
Because the kind
of guy that he is,
I just dropped if
off at his kind
of where he does his surgeries
as an MP in Islington.
And I thought, how
am I going to know?
And because whatever
you think about Corbyn,
the guy's got
integrity, I think.
He's got political integrity
and integrity as a person.
And I thought, I'm sure
he's going to declare--
like working for the BBC
or lots of institutions--
if someone gives you a
present above a certain value,
you've got to make a
declaration about it
so that you are not susceptible
to bribery, particularly
as an MP.
But I haven't seen him make a
declaration about his shirts.
It may well be that
he just passed them
on to his nearest charity shop.
Who knows?
But I'm pretty positive
that I've seen that.
So like I say, that's happened.
Something of that ilk.
Those are just a
few quick examples.
And there are literally
hundreds of others.
That's happened every 24
hours for the last 1,136 days.
People are really into it.
You know the Paul Graham guy.
And if you haven't read
Paul Graham's essays about--
well, about
everything basically.
But the guy is super
articulate and incredibly kind
of perceptive.
But one of the things
that he's said in his--
he writes an essay
about getting traction
for whatever your new
business is initially,
and how it is you find
your first customers.
And he said-- and this
really resonated with me--
you're much better
off creating something
that 100 people absolutely love
rather than 1,000 people think
is kind of OK.
And that I thought was going
to be my kind of guiding
light with this project.
That's what I'm going to do.
Find something that
people are super into,
rather than the kind of
slightly ambivalent thing
that occasionally I
might dip in or out of.
And because these
are frequent what
you'd call in TV world
appointment to view slot,
because every day at
6:00, something new
is getting published, there's
a reason to keep coming back.
So people's reactions
have been amazing.
I would defy you
actually without sounding
too kind of self-congratulatory
and annoying about it
to find a website which
has as positive feedback
as this one does.
It's great for press,
because you're always
doing something,
or invariably doing
something which is either
positive or mischievous,
and totally, like I was
saying, the juxtaposition
of things which are slightly
kind of anti-authority
meets things which are just
kind of kind and positive.
You know, existing in that space
is good for social sharing.
And then yeah, and now as a
lucky percentage of you have,
I did a book deal about a
year ago to write a book.
And basically what
I've done there
is to take 99 of
the most popular,
or wishes that just
appealed to me.
So it's a selection of 99 of
the 1,000-plus that there have
been.
And it attempts to articulate
in a reasonably kind
of lighthearted
fashion how it is
that you can get a little
bit closer to the aspirations
that you might have.
And so it's like a
kind of self-help book
for people who would never
read self-help books.
And as you said at the
start of the conversation,
it's designed to dip in
and out of classic book
to have by the bath, basically.
And so other publishers around
the world have picked that up.
I don't know that everyone's
going to do these 99 covers.
That was an idea that I
had that I never thought--
initially I thought,
let's do 5 covers.
Because I was quite into this.
You know, sometimes
you'll see a magazine
like "Vogue" published
with five different covers,
or "GQ" for their Man
of the Year awards.
And one will have Tiny Tim, and
one will have Michael Caine,
or whatever.
And I thought, that must work
quite well on the newsstand.
Otherwise, they wouldn't do
the incremental investment
to do that.
I wonder whether that could work
for a display in a bookshop.
And it does actually
look nice in the--
when you see them all together.
This is at the publishing house.
This is something I took this
photo the week before last.
When you see all 99
together, there's
a kind of visual gratification.
And I guess it's
illustrative in the fact
that these-- without being
too hackneyed about it--
these wishes are
super kind of diverse.
And no two are like.
That was the underlying point.
And the designers did a
brilliant job on that,
you know.
The tone of it is
designed, as you'll see,
to be kind of light-hearted
and accessible.
So I wish I could
have a dirty weekend.
I wish they made gentleman
like they used to.
I wish I could find the best
slice of pie in the world.
Which I have found the best
But that's another story.
So it's not-- I hope, anyway--
too kind of earnest
in that regard.
So those of you who
have got a copy,
I really hope you
enjoy reading it.
Do post a review on Amazon
if that is the case.
Meanwhile, so I'm thinking,
what can I do with this thing?
I've managed to make it kind
of not too expensive to run.
As I say, I'm a massive disciple
of the lean startup ideology.
So you would be surprised how
little it has cost to do it.
But you can see
from those examples
that I gave you, it
doesn't cost that much
to send a bunch of places to a
far right leader, for example.
They don't need to be
enormous, grandiose gestures,
these things.
But I was thinking, how
am I going to make this
like a commercial proposition?
And in a way, is it
going to spoil the fact?
Because no one's ever
been charged for anything.
Is it going to kind of soil
it or somehow compromise it
if it becomes something which
has got this commercial overlay
on top of it?
So my solution to
that, such as it was--
I may well be proved completely
wrong, but this is my endeavor,
and I'll try and be
successful in achieving it--
was to say, OK.
So let's see if we can make it
kind of cross-platform entity.
I've got ideas
around live events.
There's a website.
There's an app.
There's a book, as I say, which
you have in front of you now.
And then I thought, OK.
Let's see what we could
do with a TV show.
Because wish
fulfillment in TV terms,
it's been a huge kind of genre.
And if you can get
it right, then it's
fantastic, because
it's heartwarming.
It appeals across a huge
kind of demographic.
And particularly large
commercial stations like ITV
are really into programs
where the whole family
is gathered in front of the
screen rather than a singular
demographic.
They don't really sell a
singular demographic in the way
that a niche website might.
They sell reach.
And they sell particular
kind of profiles
around adults with children,
et cetera, et cetera.
So if you can get it
right, then it's cool.
But I didn't want
to do something
which was so kind of vanilla
or lowest common denominator
that it felt like
it wasn't adhering
to the spirit of
the project today.
And so I got a
little bit of cash
from a network in
the States, actually.
And then I linked up with a
guy called Ryan McPherson, who
I only knew by reputation,
who runs a slightly
shadowy collective of--
it's like an anarchic
kind of art collective
of graffiti artists
and civil activists who
exist as this kind
of shadowy force
who can be marshaled
when given an instruction
from their leader.
I know that makes it sound
slightly kind of cult-like.
But they do very cool things.
And so I thought he'd
be good to work with.
So he's based in Las Vegas.
So I flew out to LA.
He came down from Las Vegas.
We had a little pot of cash
that the network had given us.
And so I'll show you now
the film that we shot,
which is like what they
call a sizzle reel,
which you then take
out to broadcasters
and see whether
or not they think
there might be potential
in developing it further.
So you can see
there, like I say,
a kind of combination
of things which
are random acts of kindness
meet the articulation,
I suppose-- and
obviously I realize
that Donald Trump is like
a super kind of lazy target
for anything satirical.
And I realize also that he
was democratically elected.
But it is additionally
the case that there's
an overwhelming number
of people who are
pleased to see him lampooned.
And so as I say, the
site isn't miraculously
claiming that they'll be able
to remove him from power.
You're just doing something
to kind of visualize
the wish that people have made.
And so the ambition, as I say--
oh, wait, I've gone too far--
is to have this brand that
lives in every vertical
or a significant
number of verticals.
So a web presence
app exists, iOS app.
I haven't done an
Android app yet.
I'm sorry about that.
I should have done.
The book, which exists.
The TV, which it depends who
is it that one partners with.
Like I say, if
you do it for ITV,
you might going to do something
slightly different to that,
which is going to be a
little bit too edgy for them.
So it depends who
your partner is.
There are a number
of people who are--
if you were looking 10,
even five years ago,
and you had a TV
idea in the States,
you could either
go to a network--
NBC, CBS, Fox, et cetera--
or you could go to a cable
operator to get your ideas
and wait.
Now those people are
still buying stuff,
although they're increasingly
risk-averse creatively.
But there's a new
generation led by Netflix
of obviously
on-demand players who
are interested in
innovative content.
And Amazon have
joined that fray now,
putting significant
budgets into originated
but scripted and unscripted.
And I think we'll see now a new
wave of Snapchat style people
who are wanting to get into
the content provision game.
And I noticed with
interest this week
that Facebook group developed a
slingbox style app that enables
you to watch Facebook videos.
Videos, obviously
amazing for them.
They're putting strategically
a whole load of stuff
around going live,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And that enables you to
watch that stuff on your TV.
So this convergence that
we've read about and heard
about for so long of all
the screens coming together
into a single entity,
that time is upon us.
The other aspect-- and
I'm not like a crazy kind
of data head kind of person.
But it is interesting to
me-- and obviously one
needs to use and harness
that data in a way which
is respectful and appropriate.
But the idea that people
volunteer information
about the things they
most want in the world,
and then something meaningful
happens as a result, I think
is a kind of powerful one.
One of the reasons,
he said, stating
the blindingly
obvious that Google
is the extraordinary
company that it is in terms
of its cultural impact and
in terms of its moneymaking
abilities is that if I put
into Google as a search term
"flowers in Brighton"
or "flights to Paris"
or "therapist in London"
or whatever it may be,
that's a pretty strong
indicator that I'm in demand
for those things, thus
people competing to bid
on those key search terms.
And so I wouldn't want to take
this into a kind of territory
whereby one was aggressively
exploiting that.
I'm not suggesting that you
guys do that, by the way.
But the idea that--
and I haven't fully
developed this thought.
So you have to bear with me,
as it is only partially formed.
But the idea of fleshing
out and making a bit more
human and a bit more
rounded and a bit more
as we are as individuals
those kind of requests whereby
your prosaic transactional
requirements have
a kind of counterbalance
of things which
are a bit more intrinsic and a
bit more kind of interdirected.
That feels interesting
to me potentially.
And I think that we will
see outside of search--
let's just assume
that you guys have
nailed search, which I think we
can say that you kind of have.
But outside of that in terms
of brand-building stuff--
and search isn't always the
strongest way to build a brand
and make a contribution to that.
But I think the most
resonant brands in the future
are going to be looking for
these cross-platform solutions.
They're looking for meaningful
data, not anonymous reach.
And that is one of the reasons
why commercially for example,
a organization
like "The Guardian"
and the massively
kind of deferential
towards "The Guardian" in
terms of their editorial stance
in the world.
But one of the issues
that they had commercially
is I think they went
through a period of thinking
that reach and scale
was going to be enough.
Oh, we're in Australia now.
We're in the States now.
We've got this bureau, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
Actually advertisers
need something
and want something slightly
more sophisticated than that.
And anonymous reach
is increasingly quite
a tricky thing to monetize.
You know, they want
meaningful insight.
Again, stating the
blindly obvious.
But engaging content,
not broadcast messages.
Rich experiences, not just
conventional kind of media.
And also, I think particularly
for the kind of Generation X,
a--
I don't mean this like some
kind of quasi-religious sense.
But being possessed of
a higher purpose, not
a purely transactional thing.
What is it beyond enriching
your small group of shareholders
that you're honored to do.
What contribution is your
brand making to the world?
I think that's a super
important kind of thing.
And finally, you know, we're
all super adept at zoning out
advertising messages.
If they do reach us,
we're likely to be
cynical about them.
But we try as hard as
we can to avoid them.
We have ad blockers,
pop-up blockers.
We have spam filters.
We have signs on our
letterbox saying no junk mail.
We have PVRs that enable
us to fast forward
through the ads times 30.
And so I think increasingly--
I'm not one of those
people who says,
oh, that game's over,
blah, blah, blah.
I don't think it is over at all.
But what is the case is
that it is irrefutable
that if you are associated
with an action as a brand,
that is something which has
taken place and happened
in the real world.
And so if I was creating
a kind of mini-model
in terms of how it is
that brands should engage
with their consumers
in the future,
I would say that do
something meaningful.
Do something special that
resonates with people.
And then use media
to shine a light
on what it is that you've
done, and encourage people
to kind of share it.
And I think that if
one gets that right,
that can be quite
kind of powerful.
So like I say, I don't
know whether people still
talk about moonshots.
You know, you used to hear that
phrase "moonshots" in terms
of something which
feels like a large idea
that you probably
won't necessarily
be successful in achieving.
But nevertheless, you
don't let that prevent you
from setting out
on the endeavor.
And I think here--
and this, as I say,
I've done this
completely on my own.
Occasionally my
girlfriend helps me out.
Intimately I have an intern.
But I kind of find that managing
the interns-- that basically
easier just to kind
of do it myself.
So this is how far I've got
on my own with no money, no VC
capital, anything of that kind.
And fundamentally,
when you boil it down,
this is a place where anyone can
share the things they most want
in the world.
They can articulate
those things.
And a meaningful outcome
occurs as a result.
And that, to me, feels
like a pretty big thought
that I've only gone like a tiny,
tiny distance of scratching
1% of the surface of.
But that's my kind
of like guiding star
in terms of the core principle
from which I will not
kind of deviate.
And as I say, were one to
amplify that as an idea,
I think that conceivably
is a genuinely huge thing.
So you know, it's really
not like a big deal--
this thing.
And because I haven't quite
worked out a monetization
model, I was in this
slightly weird situation
where normally everyone's
super-obsessed with getting
users.
And we've got these
growth hacking techniques.
And there's entire
industries that
have grown up around how it
is that you acquire and hold
on to users, et
cetera, et cetera.
This isn't like that.
Because I didn't really
know what I was doing.
I just wanted to do
something cool every day.
And I know that sounds
a bit ridiculous.
But that is genuinely
the activity
that I've been engaged with.
But there are a load of
wishes on the site now.
There are too many, actually.
And one of the things that I--
one of the aspects of the
experience which doesn't work--
and I could do an entire
longer presentation about all
the flaws in this
idea, I hasten to add--
is that if you put a wish
on the site at the moment,
like layers of
sedimentary rock, you've
got to kind of get through
loads before it gets to the top.
It's not quite as tricky as
one necessarily might think.
But that can be a
bit de-motivating.
And back to my original problem.
When I put that thing on there,
and then nothing happens.
No one agrees with me.
No one likes my wish.
That's the kind of thing that
can be disproportionately
depressing.
And so sometimes I wonder in
this ephemeral, disappearing
photos age in which
we live, maybe
I should just reset the
board every day at 6:00.
And all the wishes
should vanish.
And then people remake them.
But maybe that itself
would be like a laborious
and de-motivating
experience to have
to once again put it on there.
So there are loads of things
still to kind of crack.
But currently, if
hypothetically speaking,
I stop taking wishes
today, and just thought,
I'll action all the wishes
that are on the site currently,
it would take me over 30 years
to get through all the ones
that are currently there,
which I haven't got time to do.
Anyway.
I'm at of the 45-minute mark.
So I've slightly gone over.
Thank you very
much for listening.
I really appreciate it.
It's a great
privilege to be here.
We've got a little bit
of time for questions,
if anyone's got anything that
they would like to ask me.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Sorry.
I cam in a little
bit late, and--
BILL GRIFFIN: You
probably have no idea
of what I'm talking about.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What am I doing here?
No.
Just, you may have explained
this at the beginning.
I was just wondering
how you fund it all.
Is it sort of self-funded?
BILL GRIFFIN: Well, it's a
kind of combination of things.
It's at the kind of
size now where say--
and this is a true example.
So it's an easy one to give you.
Quite a lot of the
wishes seem to relate
to a low level of anxiety
where people are articulating
the fact that their
lives haven't quite
turned out in the way that they
hoped they might, basically.
So say the wish was I wish I
didn't feel so anxious, which
I've had a bunch of times.
I could then-- as I've done--
reach out to-- there's a little
brand called Rescue Remedy.
Do you know that brand?
It comes in a
little [INAUDIBLE].
And you put a couple--
It might be psychosomatic.
I've got no idea.
But it claims to work.
Chills you out and stills
an overactive mind.
So I can say to them--
and herein, I think, lies
something potentially again,
quite big.
Because what advertising
does historically
is advertising vomits all
this stuff into the world,
and hopes that it mops up a
few people who are in market
for what it is that
it's got to offer.
Whereas what it is
that I'm offering
is a whole load of people
who have self-electedly
raised their own hands to
say, I am feeling anxious.
So that's really valuable data.
So I can in my, as I say,
low level way-- it is just me
in my bedroom kind of thing.
I can say to people--
I can say that due
to Rescue Remedy,
I've got a lot of people
here who have already
told me that they feel anxious.
You claim to make
this great product.
Why don't you send a
sample of your product
to each of these people?
And if it's as good
as you claim it is,
I'm sure you'll have
some customers for life.
Or if it cures their anxiety,
you probably wouldn't, would
you?
But you get the point.
The fact is that
it's really valuable
to be able to have a
conversation with a brand
and say, I've got
people who are in market
for what it is that you do.
And so I've been able to do
that, which enables, therefore,
the end user to
get a good result.
I put this wish on
a random website.
And now someone's
actually sent me
a physical thing in the mail.
That's cool.
So that's a great
result for them.
And it hasn't cost
me anything to do it.
So that's one way
in which I do it.
Sometimes I spend
my money on it.
But I try not to for
obvious kind of reasons.
And sometimes-- and I'm
reasonably good at doing this--
I'll create a solution which
I think is potentially potent,
but doesn't necessarily have
a huge budget attached to it.
So the examples that I gave--
I'm not sure what point you
came into the presentation,
my friend-- but
the examples that I
gave were all pretty
low cost things
that people seemed to enjoy.
So it doesn't need
to cost the earth.
My worry-- and I easily
could have, I think--
this has slightly lessened
now, because we're
in an economically more
uncertain time because
of Brexit, et cetera, et cetera.
But there was a time
a couple of years
ago where it was quite easy
to get, let's say, 200 grand
or something seed money from
a wannabe tech investor.
The issue then becomes
their business plan
becomes your business plan.
And I didn't want--
the management of
minority investing
is a pain in the ass
at the best of times.
But I wasn't quite sure how
to make money out of it,
and whether or not
the way in which
I thought I might
ultimately make money
was going to be something
that they enjoyed.
So I just thought,
I'm just going
to retain 100% of the equity
and just do it myself.
I don't know whether that was
the right decision or not.
But that's what I've done.
AUDIENCE: And so in
this sort of world
of fake news, how
have you thought
about sort of guarding against
becoming a propaganda machine.
I'm thinking about the
Donald Trump thing.
Now that he knows that that
happened, which he probably
didn't like very much--
BILL GRIFFIN: I doubt
he loves too much.
He seems pretty thick-skinned.
AUDIENCE: But now
that that's come out,
maybe now people will start
to look at your platform
and take it much more
seriously, and then
sort of try to
battle against it.
So how have you thought
about how you might--
BILL GRIFFIN: Well,
I mean, my response
is maybe a tiny bit in terms
of what I've done so far
might be inadequate.
I'd be happy to concede
that it has been.
What I've done is to when I
write out-- what I generally
do is like post the
photo of the thing,
and then do a couple of
hundred words of copy,
sometimes a bit less.
And I'm at pains to
point out that we
don't have a kind of
political dog in the fight,
et cetera, et cetera.
So stress the neutrality
of the platform.
And what I've also found is
that in the case of UK politics,
I have done--
so I did that Corbyn thing.
That slightly sarcastic
attack on the leader
of the opposition, I suppose.
"Attack" is too strong a word.
But you know what I mean.
A bit of a diss.
I did a Ed Miliband
thing where people
wish that their MPs spent
more time in the constituency
that they're ostensibly
meant to represent.
So I sent Ed Miliband a
map of his constituency
in North Yorkshire,
where he apparently
was very infrequently seen.
I've done a bunch of
David Cameron things.
I did a thing once
with another politician
whereby it was a
kind of trade thing,
basically where he wasn't
doing enough with free trade.
So I sent him a load of
bananas, et cetera, et cetera.
So if I was to evaluate it,
everyone has been kind of-- not
as I say, that anyone is
losing any sleep over it.
But everyone's been
tarred with the same brush
in that to the extent.
AUDIENCE: If they're starting to
see that something will happen
if a wish with them attached
to it starts becoming a thing,
that they might
start going right.
This wish about
Donald Trump being
shown for who he is actually
needs to be stopped.
And then they try to stop
it from becoming the wish.
You know that sort of--
BILL GRIFFIN: Yeah.
I guess you'd have to kind of--
the stars that I've taken
so far-- and as I say,
if a sufficient
number of people feel
that this is something
they want to see
happen, I'm not a
political person.
But I will make your wish--
naked Trump statue, whatever--
I will make it kind of manifest.
But whilst doing that, I'm going
to stress that personally, I
don't have an opinion
about Donald Trump, which
is a service that brings
things to life that otherwise,
as I say, would remain
tweets or whatever.
SPEAKER: I think maybe we have
time for maybe one or two more
questions.
There is one here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
BILL GRIFFIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: What's your trickiest
wish been to manifest?
Have you had one that's
ever really stumped you?
BILL GRIFFIN: Well, because
I suppose I have a bit of a
get out, because I'm
not, like I said,
I'm not guaranteeing to kind
of make this stuff come true.
I'm just doing a tiny gesture.
So generally I only
set out to do something
that I know I can
achieve by 6:00.
And I learned the hard
way early on where
I would find myself thinking
about what the train times were
down to Kent, so I could
do some prank on Nigel
Farage or something.
And then I think, I haven't
got time to do this.
I'm going to have to give
them a downloadable poster
or something instead.
So generally, I don't
come unstuck that often.
I haven't missed one, yet.
But definitely some of them
are more testing than others.
And I'll think to myself, OK.
What am I actually
going to do here?
And typically, those are the
more conventional wishes where
someone will say, my
son is really ill.
And he just wants
to go to Disneyland.
And because one thinks about
wishes in that kind of sense,
I think, because you've
seen that on TV programs,
or you've read about
it on the press,
or you saw some Go Fund Me that
went really well, or whatever.
So quite often,
those are the times
when I feel like I'm
disappointing people a bit.
Because I will help
them with that.
I'll publicize their campaign.
I'll tell the story.
And I'll amplify it so
that people who follow me
on social media or whatever, all
of which is kind of positive.
But there's a part of
me that's thinking,
when they put that
wish on the site,
they thought they were
going to be getting tickets
to Disneyland the next day.
So that's the kind of time
where I think, oh shit.
You know, that's something
that they're maybe
going to find that a
little bit underwhelming.
But although having
said that, no one's
ever gotten in touch with
me and said, oh my God.
That was so lame when
you did that thing.
I hate you.
They might have thought it.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested to know
your thought process around how
you keep control of the actions,
and whether or not you've
considered sort of outsourcing
to the people on the site.
Cause when you said about the
old people home, with the users
you could have scaled
that so everyone did.
But then as we went
through the presentation,
I was like, oh no.
You probably want to keep
control of most of these.
BILL GRIFFIN: Yeah.
I've got someone I
know a little bit--
I don't know her
very well, but we've
had coffee a couple of times--
has got a site which relies on
peer-to-peer wish fulfillment.
So I go on there.
And I say, I live
in Shepherd's Bush.
And I'm having problems
with my boiler.
Both of those facts are
actually true, coincidentally.
And then someone else
says, I will totally
help you with your boiler.
And I say, oh, that's great.
We've made this fantastic
Craigslist style connection.
But simultaneously I'm mindful
of the several serial killers
who have stalked Craigslist.
And so I'm thinking,
there's a vulnerable woman
who lives on her own.
She doesn't know what
to do with her boiler.
She hasn't got the cash
that it necessitates
to get Pimlico
plumbers out, which
is in my experience,
many hundreds of pounds.
And so this guy, who
I have effectively
brokered an introduction
to, is going
to manifest on her doorstep.
I don't know who
that fucking guy is.
He could be absolutely anyone.
And so that's one
of the reasons.
And that kind of stuff--
aside from how hideous
some kind of incident would
be of that nature, obviously--
but that shit can kill a
platform in seconds, rightly.
You know, I'm amazed that Airbnb
have come back so many times
from people trashing
apartments in New York,
and having amphetamine-fueled
gay orgies,
and all this kind of crazy
stuff that's happened there
on many, many occasions.
And in fairness to
Brian Chesky and co.
They've always managed
that incredibly well.
But I didn't want to
be dealing with that.
And so I thought that
if I'm in charge of it,
that works better.
And it de-risks it.
And editorially, I can
sign off my own kind
of idea, which in
implementational terms
just makes it way simpler.
It's like working
for an ad agency
and pitching an
idea to the client,
and then going to sit in the
client's chair and say, yeah.
I buy your idea.
It makes it much, much
easier, because I've
got to do something every day.
There are, however,
occasions where
if it's publicizing
someone's fundraising
idea or a little boy wants
a load of birthday cards,
or whatever.
I just say, look.
Send me all the birthday cards.
I'll package them up
into a single parcel,
which makes more sense.
Easier, domestic.
Cost of a stamp of
an international.
And I'll send them all.
And that works
really, really well.
Or people will get in
touch with me directly.
And again, it says
on the site, if you
think you can help
out, then email me.
And then I can slightly
vet that person.
So they'll say, look, I'm great
at public speaking or helping
people overcome
confidence issues.
And here's my
credentials for that.
And then I can say, OK.
Let's meet and have
a cup of coffee.
And I've met loads
and loads of people.
Because very
frequently the wishes
relates to our career
dilemmas and so on.
So I just say, look.
Come in.
We'll have a conversation.
And we'll meet.
And that's invaluable
kind of feedback to get.
Oh, how did you find
out about this site?
Blah, blah, blah.
About 98% of the time I
retain that control myself,
just because, as I say,
it would terrify me
to broker two strangers,
introduce them to each other.
That could be weird.
Is that it?
Is it time up?
It's half past 1:00.
You need to get back, guys.
SPEAKER: Thank you very
much for coming, Bill.
It's been really fascinating.
BILL GRIFFIN: Thank you
very much for listening.
I really appreciate it.